hi mr. cucumber hi Ben
do you mind if I eat you no not at all
Ben I'll write them I would probably not
do this for anyone else so I don't
really even like cucumbers and you'll
probably get a dirty SMS message about
this later so here we go
friends of one-plus British Columbia
real nice Tom you
gets me sense that your phone may take
days so it always takes longer than you
think
settle so we finally on that plane
remember good day
she can't stop hatin on herself
scabs are wonderful boy
Oh
I miss you
wanna take your walks sure you do
you
oh wait I almost forgot Oh gone happy
birthday Molly happy birthday to you I
mean hey Molly
happy birthday hope you have a great one
oh so we'll hope you have a great day
Molly and happy birthday once again I'm
sorry Molly I don't think I can finish
this I'm not as big on my vegetables as
you are but regardless happy birthday
all right charlie I hope that's what you
needed because it didn't taste very good
and people look at you strange when you
go to the grocery store and just buy one
cucumber like really strange my men take
easy